there have been more airstrikes in Iraq
which we understand have targeted the
iran-backed popular mobilization forces
it's happened near a camp in Taji north
of Baghdad the Reuters news agency is
reporting two vehicles for his killing
six people now speaking earlier on the
phone Al Jazeera's Osama bin Javaid said
the popular mobilization forces is
saying the convoy was full of medics not
fighters according to popular
mobilization forces the paramilitary
wing of the Iraqi government
we've heard that are denying that any of
the leaders of the mobilization forces
or affiliates were in that convoy have
we discussed earlier that was targeted
on party road
this is a road which leads towards the
area ontology which is also home to a
major coalition pace there was earlier
speculation that there was some come one
of the brigades who was in this vehicle
convoy which was faceted allegedly by US
missiles but so far the popular
mobilization forces saying that men of a
home invaded this was a medic convoy
which was targeted so attention remains
high in Iraq and security remains very
tight we've seen in the last few hours
more about input for streets being
closed in Baghdad ahead of the funeral
procession of Romanian behind this and
contraband